sono creati da gregorio ci posso credere
ho attivato una leva
[Applauso]
dove stai andando
bene sono spesso guardate un po kitsch e
trash grappa il nonno e c'è anche la
figlia di lei sappiamo il nuovo gioco
che non abbiamo mai provato il miur è
un'edizione speciale di green in cui
anche noi possiamo trasformarci in grado
finalmente torniamo nel gioco di g se ci
seguite da tanto sapete che abbiamo
fatto tanti giochi di grant se non li
avete visti poi andate a vederli mauro
avete tv covo di preti fortorina sono
bel mi piace iniziamo subito io dominio
questi qua qua ci siamo qua c'è vitale
allora dobbiamo votare hanno alloggiato
nave la causa perché ci sono bambini di
vini sono g io sono
la parodia vita ci dobbiamo giocata
laredo vitale g innanzitutto gli altri
giocatori
sono giù in garage no perché io non lo
chiamo il garage ricordate la musica di
granito con tutte le bollette tocchiamo
un pochino tagia non saranno devo
ascoltare che cosa è questa cosa il
braccio di chi
chi c'era a dio ho visto col culo
nessuno
[Musica]
gabana
ha fatto giusto in tempo per di essere
al sicuro qua dentro io vado più tardi
scendera già allora c'era qualcuno che
si era nascosto in garage all italianità
ho sentito che apriva la porta
che dà il quadro è proprio un pezzo
d'arte moderna è previsto questo quadro
non vorrebbe un quadro del genere nella
propria casa o io non voto diede mio
volto dobbiamo prima che arrivi il nonno
e così è successo che cosa ho fatto che
viene in atto un bel niente non voglio
fare un altro giocatore e si è eliminato
piano piano tutti che
che guarda con gli occhi rossi e
bellissimi dove si trova peccato che ha
rubato un occhio
rimandano ancora tre per eliminare anita
ho sostituito lama lorenza e kita che un
libro che sia più utile
devo prendere questa così può sparare
premi con questa sorta di chiusa da
trovare la chiave
cerchiamo la chiave così poi eliminiamo
draghi ma mi sa che sei rimasto solo tu
hai detto tu non dovete the giocatori
sono tutti specifiche bel ritratto di
famiglia dove sei
tu che cosa devo guardare i segreti di g
ho attivato una leva
[Applauso]
dove stai andando spostati non vedo più
dovresti dov'è andata dove si è scappata
il piccolo
magistrati ma
segreto che sono dovuti a segreto in cui
tinini
mettiamo il libro qua
premesso che dove credi un credito testo
che cosa hai fatto al nonno poverino non
riesco a prenderla i dieci fuori che ti
devo prendere
una rivincita
subito allora votiamo la casa io lo voto
il la scuola a scuola si può notare la
ascolta scuola possiamo andare a scuola
con grandi
avuto la scuola chi ci sarà questa volta
allora non sono gay non sono in chi nel
chiuso delle pareti sottili ma anche noi
però io vorrei mi ero subito così italia
avevo appena smo perdo i decreti di
graham i miei eliminato
[Musica]
roma ok sono morta quindi ora sono un
fantasma spettatrice e vediamo che cosa
stanno facendo allora parlo
prevediamo unità le basta sta facendo
ecco lo sto andando un po in giro a
cercare qualcosa e devi trovare gli
oggetti ma bisogna stare anche il primo
mese cremini non è bello no non c'è
niente uffa io speravo di trovare
qualcosa da mangiare almeno gran fretta
la retroguarda dentro gli armadi sto
controllata allora controllo dove credi
dove
sta scendendo le scale o quindi sto
parlando qui credo di fila
38 scappato dopo aver cui uno ha
cambiato strada andato a prendere un
altro giocatore perché più lento ok qui
c'è qualcosa si vuole
come si chiama pure
per aprire la porta e forse quella è la
via d'uscita si l'avete sentita
carnago di
mi ha visto abbiamo visto non lo sto
aspettando
si si si sta andando verso l'alto
direttore bene che scappavano silvio
come senso viene un'idea davvero ma mi
sta ancora inseguendo testa che ti sei
fermo all'ora salto su ma credo che
aspetto lascerà scappare ho trovato la
sala da pranzo nodi marmi trarre e poi
dice qualcosa di aiuto layer quistello
beckham non si può correre in qualche
modo ciao ho trovato qualcun altro
quindi fermata ha trovato quella
giocatrice che si era nascosta o no ma
la presa la sta prendendo qualcosa in
vista che rimarrà il master che sono
stati
quindi forse servirà ad aprire la porta
forse riesce a scappare con quello
navata principale forse qui si sono
riuscito ad aprire l'occhietto rosso ora
manca solo quella blu e poi e poi da
malore
sacco di altra cosa sta girando nella
scuola non so esattamente che punto si
sa dove sia appena chiesa la beffa dell
aiuto di miss e mister seguendo si è
nascosta dietro alla porta
qui c'è un apporto è in bagno grelli
anche lei deve andare bene
ho trovato qualcosa o la chiave la
chiave per prendere la fionda per ogni
mese con la fionda
che strano come cammini strisciando
allora dov'era forse finali qui ho
trovato qui
dunque sono chiavi anche da sotto levice
apprezza per no però adesso cielo fionda
e meglio la chiave no voglio tirare la
fionda
fondate o privi breve
perché non me lo farò attira tu
o no ma le cose ma da no perché ho
finito le munizioni ecco perché no
allora meglio che sky si erano qui
c'erano le pietre ok ora riesci a
beccarla
troppo bello vedere gravi così non ci
vedevo che rimanga sempre così anno c'è
più tempo
rispetto e una frana normale
tutto ok insomma non c'è più
l'avrà preso qualche altro giocatore
speriamo che abbiano aperto qualche
porto andiamo a trovare qualcos'altro
dobbiamo trovare la chiave blu qualcuno
ha aperto la cassaforte ha lasciato una
chiave la chiave della cassaforte ma
insomma che avremmo trovato dentro la
cassaforma lusso la chiave blu
per un pelo tz alvato un anno sono
troppo forte non sono rimasto bloccato
non sono riuscito a ritrovare
quella tra le creme la messa
la rivincita
prendiamoci la rivincita e allora
bisogna andare nel resort nel resort
ceresoni 12 aree gioco uscirà concreti
lei ma la palla che rotola
eccoci allora non sono io grande anch'io
onorare questo il restore wow ma tutti
al resort sembrano delle prigioni e
infatti non sembra proprio compresa
sembrato un ideale per g ma se la statua
di di grandpa che il marito e nonno con
due sci ho trovato un martello
prendi lo vedo meno ragusa 6 ott il e
bowling si è tenuto lo fanno lo zen
grendi gioca boni
una sala giochi a notte ma dopotutto
aspetto quindi tu non sei nella strada
giochi no sono dove c'è la statua di
impresa è preso la palla da bowling no
ho preso il martello facciamo perché se
prendi la palla da bowling sì c'è una
strada giochi bowling in cui puoi usare
la palla da bowling e giocheremo a meno
che in prima
persona fanno da bowling ok allora
tipo non mi ricordo tutto dritto e una
cabina che oggi vive tutto dritto
ecco dire
allora devo mettere la palla dentro quei
strike mai messa dai
principi dalla rossa impregna di un po
più fresca servirà però c'è scritto
shakey quindi a ma qualcuno si è rubato
il premio che premiano qui c'era scritto
pro nyse vedi
turbato tech
strike
parole chiave rossa dai andiamo dove sei
io sono appena uscito fuori da minimi
sono dove c'è la statua del nonno allora
aspetta ha caricati ok apriamo con
questa chiave e prendere una le regole
figlio guarda io aperto trovato qualcosa
grande è la chiave di t c'è chi è
praticamente c'è un cui si chiama e il
baule baule crugnola troviamo il baule
da bere ma tu sei treni nel frat membro
che non si è nati c'è un baule
ritrovato il baule d'aversa vieni sempre
salvo il martello michael dingman qui
in una cabina
sono sotto la cabina del bowling e qui a
youtube ma con il cartello seguimmo e
che
vedi qui c'è una scatola colpisce col
martello questo che
cosa c'era dentro fu cacciavite a tutti
voi che ci facciamo col cacciavite
adesso la parola preso potrebbe servirci
ha lasciato il martello si o no il mio
biglietto più mi mancano solo due minuti
andiamo verso la montagna qua si che
cosa hai trovato
con il cacciavite ho tolto questa parte
buy ha bisogno di come si chiama e mi
omaggio un gran aggio per poi azionare
qua e scappare
però tutto l'ingranaggio mandato
6.48 secondo il furbo
se l'affare dove saranno nascosto
l'ingranaggio
scritto exit
remote control
codice you scherzo te sono riuscito a
scappare se non ci può scappare come fa
sono entrato li dovete vederlo inserito
allora
si
sono creati dentro greco bilanci pastore
6 a
4 3 io avrei nomi dove si nasconderà
vincere grandi vitale e ischia e quello
che fa chi disegnerà la macchina con i
denti e la lingua quindi sei in garage
tipo un anno non sono i garage
ha fatto io sono grandi non ho bisogno
di trovare gli indizi è infatti ho
trovato due giocatori qui e quindi due
in uno sì adesso che sto inseguendo uno
è la prenderò ma prenderò
scappati tutti e due
il colore quel corpo con gli occhi rossi
e cosa che c'è qui
ma non è mica sei dio tu
ti sei nascosta
e ci sono più i di pietro non mi puoi
più prendere qualcuno ha aperto la
cassaforte la mia casa morte aiuto
grandi vitale nasconde il cibo nella
cassaforte ho bisogno della master chin
ha chiuso dove tra l'altro
ha ancora quella mano
ho detto sì
stiamo in una nuova mappa la mention
centra con i giovani la casa è molto
grande ei che cosa perché c'è
treno quanto erano forse riusciamo a
scappare con il treno per prendere il
biglietto e poi riuscì a mappare ho
visto che si può prendere lì dalla
macchinetta però servono i soldi ok
allora dobbiamo trovare i soldi e varie
chiavi sicura mai mai cerchio che ho
trovato in piedi di porco mini posto
aprire vedi qui c'è la macchinetta per
prendere i biglietti eccola ho ritrovato
la scatola che cosa hanno in mano li un
pupazzo di non hanno detto sono serve
per sorrentino è bravo a non far bene
faccio niente ormai dobbiamo su
cerchiamo delle monete per prendere i
biglietti infatti era questa più
importante
attenta a non evocare la ndrina livello
infatti qualcuno è finito male quanto
sapete storia di colloqui sono qui
dietro d'italia wow qualche grande
questa casa a questa è la casa d g
20 si mi ricordava qualcosa vi ricordate
grandi di me facciano luce rossa
gara troppo dietro credo ok credo che
sergio brio alla testa
niente
ma tutti i ricordi dov'era la
cosa devo fare
non lo sono lasciata tranquilla
fortemente inseguirà se lo lasci
tranquillo forse non ti seguono ok
è sparita eh sì perché è nero l'italia
ci dona chiave grande acceleratore
l'allenatore della macchina forzati
forse dobbiamo scappare con bella con la
macchina
con gli occhi rossi che servirà qualcosa
ma non riesco a capire cosa ha bisogno
della legna il corpo di gremi con una
chiave sono io la legna veramente veri e
rapportato al journal tumino perché lo
di sotto ciò detto emiliano ok se ne
scopriremo a prenderebbe stacchino che
però sarebbe meglio vanno bella fa
pregare perché c'è questa forza si è
trovata
faccia la sola moneta three biglietto
trovato l'operaio aveva preso un presa
vieni ma tu vedi una moneta qui per caso
viene inseguimento nel lavandino
in questo lavandino vedi la moneta non
l'hai già presentato non allora cielo
sono via via non è che non scappare nei
magari diciamo che a salire tutti e due
le altre sento dei rumori strani però la
legna la puoi mettere qui guarda no non
sia sostituito
c'è allora proviamo come si fa a
scendere da qui no ma questo non
tradiremo allora mettiamo i soldi
perché non devi fare un
via soldi e uscito bene
preso ok guardiamo il treno mi
raccomando rimane vicino a me così
entriamo insieme
si vedrà dove si entra da qui e adesso
parti quando non mi dire che
no
ci vuole un acceleratore truciolari è
una chiave del treno dice
no questo partito
arrivano
allora te ma non disperiamo troviamo la
chiave dell'acceleratore e la chiave
d'estate a mettere fuori felice a questa
già allora tie dye ce la possiamo fare
ma solo in un minuto o non competono il
minuto dobbiamo trovare l'acceleratore
la chiave del 3 mastrangelo gemetto
nobili giardino perché abbiamo visto lo
caduti non so come allora io potrebbero
essere caduti in giardino la chiave del
ripostiglio e la chiave delle armi non
funzionerà col treno vero no ci vuole
perché la chiave del treno un po no
mancano 3 1 finito o
no solo chiave del 3 ma la società c'è
male te che proviamo le altre mappe che
continuiamo questo gioco e ora mi
lasciavo
applicare per una delle nostre altri su
quella che preferite è buona ciao